شكرا للعيال اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
نتابع واياكم في هذه التغطيه المتواصله
ساعه بساعه دقيقه بدقيقه لحظه بلحظه لكل
تطورات الاحداث المشتعله في السودان حيث
الاتهامات المتبادله بين قائد الجيش
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوه
الدعم السريع محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف
بحمتي فخلال لقائهما غير المباشر عبر قناه
العربيه اتهم كل طرف الطرف الاخر ببدء
الحرب وخرق الهدنه والهجوم على منازل
السكان والبعثات الاجنبيه نتابع
[موسيقى]
البرهان وحميتي جنرالاني جنح الى الحرب
بعد ان كان السودان قاب قوسين او ادناه من
توقيع اتفاق تاريخي العربيه جمعت البرهان
وحماتي على شاشتها في حوار غير مباشر
بينهما في مقابلتين خاصتين من بدا الحرب
تم الهجوم علينا من قبل هذه المجموعات
المتمرده
من يسيطر على العاصمه وما ابرز اماكن وجود
قوات كل طرف
مطار الخرطوم في اشكاليه ومطار
لمجموعات كثيره جدا من هذه القوات وسط
الاح
ياء
فقط المهندسين
اين يوجد البرهان وحماتي انا موجود في
قياده القوات المسلحه
ومبارحه ولن ابارحها هذه هي مهنتي وهذا
شرفي
الا محمولا على
نعش
من خلق الهدنه اي هدنه اعلنت اصلا ما في
هدنه حتى ابتدات لان
القوات الطرف الاخر غير مسيطر عليها وهي
منتشره في مناطق مختلفه من الاحياء
السكنيه
من اختار الحرب عوض السلام
احنا قلنا موجودين في الق
ارات طبعا
نحن نقوم بالدفاع ولا نريد ان نخرج نخرج
الى خارج دائره الدفاع
من يستهدف المستشفيات والبعثات الاجنبيه
المنازل اخرجت
المستشفيات واحتلت المستشفيات
كيف ستنتهي المعركه
اي جهه تبدا الحرب بالتاكيد لن تعلم الى
اي مدى ستنتهي هذه الحرب انا اقول ان هذه
الحرب ليس فيها كاسد
ما يحدث في السودان لن يبقى داخله سباعيه
افريقيه قد تتاثر بتفاقم النزاع اكثر
فخروج دويل الانفجارات وقتال شوارع على
مساحه المليون و 880 الف كيلومتر مربع ليس
مستبعدا جوله اولى من حرب اهليه قد تمتد
الى سبع دول يتشارك السودان حدودا ملتهبه
معها بالاستناد الى عاملين مدى استمراريه
النزاع ونتيجته
حقائب موظبه وصرر محموله على الراس احد
مخاوف السباعيه المحيطه بالسودان وليس
اكبرها كوابيس تتسرب عبر السدود وانابيب
المياه وتتمل بعتاد حركات مسلحه عبر
الحدود التي باتت بيئه اكثر خصوبه للتمرد
اجلس الانذار التي تدق اقليميا ودوليا لا
تنحصر بكون السودان ثلث اكبر دوله في
افريقيا بل انه يمتد عبر منطقه حيويه
جيوسياسيا غير مستقره وهشه ببعض اجزائها
مصر المتعطشه للمياه اكثر دوله عربيه
اكتظاظا بالسكان وتتشارك مع السودان
تاريخا من السياسه والتجاره والثقافه
ومياه النيل فضلا عن علاقات وثيقه بالجيش
واكثر من اربعه ملايين سودانيين على
اراضيها واي اضطراب بالعمق الاستراتيجي
لمصر من شانه عرقله الجهود المشتركه
للتوصل
بشان سد النهضه التهديد المائي ليس فقط ما
تشكله اثيوبيا بطموحاتها الكهرومائيه
فالمناوشات على الحدود غير منقطعه اصلا
وقد يتسبب النزاع بعوده التوتر بمنطقه
الفشجه الخصبه الحدوديه المتنازع عليها
تشاد الجاره الغربيه الفقيره تحتضن بالاصل
نحو 400 الف نازح سوداني جراء صراعات
سابقه اضيف اليهم اكثر من عشرين الفا
مؤخرا القلق التشادينابع من مخاوف امتداد
الازمه لمناطق استقبلت اللاجئين ومعظمهم
من دارفور فتاريخ تشاد طويل مع ميليشيات
الجنجويد التي شكلت نواه قوات احمدتي
قلق مشابه يتكون غربا مرتزقه ومسلح
ميليشيات سودانيون عادوا الى بلادهم بعد
لعب دور النشط في الصراع الليبي هؤلاء على
معرفه جيده بالساحه الليبيه ومطاردتهم
داخليا قد ترميهم على الحدود مجددا اما
جنوب السودان الدوله التي استقلت حديثا
فمخاوفها تتمثل ببدء عرقله الروابط
اللوجستيه لتصريف انتاجها النفطي البالغ
170 الف برميلا يوميا عبء اقتصادي قد
تزيده سوءا عوده جماعيه لاكثر من 800 الف
لاجئ يستضيفهم السودان ازمه تتشاركها مع
اريتريا فمئه من مواطنيها قد يضطرون لحزم
امتعتهم من جديد
[موسيقى]
معنى من القاهره عطيه عيسوي الكاتب
المتخصص في الشؤون الافريقيه في صحيفه
الاهرام اهلا بك معنا استاذ عطيه مره
جديده على شاشه العربيه هل تعتقد بانه
عوامل الصراع القائمه حاليا
تبقيه في داخل السودان ام انه من الان يجب
ان نتحدث فعلا عما تعرض الى بعضه التقرير
اي امكانيه تمدد الصراع الى دول مجاوره
اهلا وسهلا استاذ طاهر الصراع
يجب التحسب له من الان وهناك دول مثل مصر
تحسبت له منذ البدايه ملنه تحسبت لنتائجه
المتعدده يعني ليس فقط مجرد نزوح الكثير
من السودانيين الى دول الجوار
واقتحامهم لاماكن ابناء قبائل اخرى يعانون
من شظف العيش وقله الموارد
وعند ذلك يمكن ان تحدث اشتباكات بين
الطرفين ويضيع فيها
تضيع فيها حياه الكثيرين وهذا حدث من قبل
مرارا ليس في السودان فقط وانما في دول
عديده شهدت صراعات هذه نقطه النقطه الاخرى
الاخطر او تداعي الاخطر هو ان
الاوضاع في السودان
يعني تحول القبضه او الحديديه على الحدود
الى قبضه مسترخيه ضعيفه يتيح الفرصه لدخول
المتطرفين والارهابيين
ليشكلوا كابوسا جديدا مره اخرى من داخل
السودان لمصر ودول الجوار الاخرى وهذا ما
تخشاه مصر وتخشاه الولايات المتحده
باعتبارها مهتمه بشؤون الامن في المنطقه
بس قبل ان اتابع معك في موضوع الجوار دول
الجوار السوداني بما انك ذكرت الولايات
المتحده ودول اخرى في الحقيقه وليس فقط
الولايات المتحده لا يبدو وفقا للبعض ان
هذه الدول اتخذت كل الاجراءات اللازمه
التي يمكن ان
تبين جزءا من العصا اذا صح التعبير
للطرفين لكي يقف القتال هما يحدان على
الهدنه وعلى وقف اطلاق النار يعني او او
هم يحضون الطرفين اقصد على ذلك ولكنهم في
الحقيقه لا يعني يهزون كل العصا
هذا صحيح وهذا يرجع اساسا الى انهم
خاصه الولايات المتحده لا يملكون اكثر من
المناشدات وابداء الاستعداد للوساطه لان
ارسال قوات امريكيه على سبيل المثال او من
اي دوله اخرى
لتتورط في احداث السودان غير مرغوب فيه
وفقا على تجارب سابقه عندما ارسلت
الولايات المتحده في عام 93
قوات الى الصومال
وغرقت هذه الخطوات في الحرب الاهليه
الصوماليه وقتل من قتل فيها وتم التمثيل
بجثث بعض الامريكيين هناك والطرق للانسحاب
لكن مشهد ماساوي للقوات الامريكيه انذاك
ولكن يعني ليس هذا هو المطلوب ولكن هناك
الكثير من الاجراءات الاخرى التي بامكان
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها ان يتخذوها لكي
يعني يوقفوا القتال او يضغط على الاقل
لتخفيفه تحدثنا كثيرا عن موضوع
العقوباتنا اولا نعم
اذا كنت تقصد العقوبات العقوبات الشعب
السوداني لا يحتمل عقوبات اقتصاديه جديده
لكن العقوبات اذا فرضت على القائدين فليس
هناك ما يضمن تنفيذها لان العقوبات التي
فرضت على البشير على سبيل المثال
وشخصيات اخرى لم تنفذ لانه ليس هناك
الذراع
التنفيذيه التي يمكن ان تنفذ قرارات
المحكمه جنايات الدوليه او قرارات مجلس
الامن تمام بس على الاقل تبين اراده
حقيقيه بان الولايات المتحده تريد توجه
رساله حقيقيه واضحه بانها تريد ان توقف
هذا الصراع لانها فعلتها وبوقت هذا جدا مع
دول اخرى
هذا هو المطلوب يعني المطلوب هو التهديد
باحاله من يعوق العوده الى السلام
ووقف الحرب الى المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
مثلا عن فرض العقوبات الاخرى على على نفس
الشخصين اذا قلنا نريد ان نلجا الى مجلس
الامن فهذا طريق شبه مسدود ايضا لانه اذا
تقدمت الولايات المتحده او اي دوله اخرى
عضو في المجلس سواء ذات عضويه دائمه او
عضويه غير دائمه فهذا
اتخاذ قرار في مجلس الامن سيتطلب عدم
استخدام الفيتو من الرئيسيه والصين وبما
ان العلاقات متوتره اساسا وهناك حرب
اعلاميه بين الطرفين بسبب اوكرانيا وبسبب
تايوان اعتقد ان انه لن يمر اي قرار من
مجلس الامن هذه النقطه وضعتها هل تريد ان
انتقل الى نقطه ثانيه لو سمحت معي استاذ
عطيه كسبا للوقت مع حضرتك الان بخصوص دول
الجوار مجددا اي الدول الاكثر هشاشه
باعتقادك التي يمكن ان تكون الاكثر تاثرا
بغض النظر عن امكانيه التسرب يعني متطرفين
الى دول حتى مثل مصر ولكن عموما اي الدول
التي تجدها في الجوار الاكثر هشاشه التي
يمكن ان تكون الاكثر تاذيا من هذا الصراع
حاليا
كل كل الدول المجاوره للسودان
باستثناء مصر وارتريا اللتين تحكمان او
تسيطراني جيدا على الحدود كل الدول هشه
وكل الدول قابله لان ينفذ منها او اليها
المتطرفون او
ينفذ اليها او يلجا اليها
المشردون واللاجئون
وكلها
نظرا لامتداد وانتشار القبائل على جانبي
الحدود مع بين السودان وتشاد وبين السودان
وافريقيا الوسطى وبين السودان
واثيوبيا
وبينها وبين اريتريا كل هذه
القبائل ستكون حاضنه
للذين سيلجاون اليها ولكن الصراع على
الموارد الشحيحه هو المرجح رغم وجود صله
قرابه
في العرقيه او في
بحكم القبيله بين
بين الذين سيلجئون من السودان الذين سيلجا
اليهم وبالتالي هل الدول الاخرى قادره على
ان لم تستطع كاتي حد افريقي مثلا او كل
الدول الراعيه من خلال الاليات والثلاثيات
والرباعيات اللي تكونت على مدى هذه
السنوات ان لم تستطع وقف الصراع في الداخل
هل هي على الاقل قادره على من التمدده
ليس هناك دوله قادره على منع
تمدد هذا الصراع
يمكن ان تمتد نيرانو الى الدول المجاوره
ربما باستثناء مصر واريتريا
الصراع بس على اي اساس عم تستند بكلامك
استاذ عطيه يعني هذا الصراع عوامل داخليه
بغض النظر عن بعض الايادي الاجنبيه ولكن
العوامل هي داخليه في الصراع بين الرجلين
ولو كان لهما مشروعان الا انه العوامل
الاخرى التي يمكن ان تمد الصراع الى دول
الجوار ما هي ما الذي سيجعل تشاد تدخل على
الصراع مثلا او جنوب السودان او اي دوله
اخرى
يعني الامر هنا
يحتاج او يمكن ان يمتد الى دول اخرى لان
القبائل المشتركه على الحدود يمكن ان
تساهم في هذا الامر يعني اذا اذا امتد اذا
اذا مثلا راى ابناء قبيله في جنوب السودان
لها امتداد داخل السودان
فربما ينضم مقاتلون منها الى
اشقائهم داخل السودان وبالتالي تنشب الحرب
وتحدث عمليات انتقاميه بعمليات
انتقاميه مضاده من من داخل السودان الى
جنوب السودان هذا الامر ينطبق ايضا على
تشاد لان هناك حوالي 17 قبيله تقريبا
مشتركه على الحدود بين البلدين هناك
في افريقيا الوسطى وهي تعاني من اضطرابات
شديده هي الاخرى منذ سنوات
الحدود ليس مسيطرا عليها وكذلك مع
جنوب السودان واثيوبيا حيث هناك لاجئون
اثيوبيون يمكن ان صحيح يشاركوا في القتال
ويمكن ايضا ان يمتد الصراع من خلال عمليات
انتقاميه من جانب من داخل السودان وعوامل
الحرب عموما مع هذين البلدين تحديدا لا
تزال قائمه يعني مع اثيوبيا ومع جنوب
السودان تحديدا القائمه مع السودان انا
اذكر معنا اشكر هذا التحليل لك استاذ عطيه
عيساوي الكاتب المتخصص في الشؤون
الافريقيه في صحيفه الاهرام من القاهره
تحياتي اليك شكرا جزيلا
اعلن وزير الخارجيه البريطاني عن اغلاق
السفاره البريطانيه في الخرطوم مؤقتا
مؤكدا ان سلامه البريطانيين في السودان
تشكل اولويه قصوى بالنسبه اليهم
لقد اتخذنا قرارا باغلاق السفاره
البريطانيه في الخرطوم مؤقتا واجلاء
الدبلوماسيين البريطانيين وعائلاتهم ونقل
وظائفنا الدبلوماسيه الى موقع دبلوماسي
قريب ونواصل العمل بشكل مباشر من خلال
شركائنا الدوليين للدعوه الى وقف اطلاق
النار ووضع حد لهذا العنف تبقى سلامه
حمايه الرعايه البريطانيه في السودان
اولويه قصوى بالنسبه لنا وسنقوم بهذا
الواجب من خلال سفاراتنا الموجوده في
المنطقه بالتنسيق الوثيق مع اصدقائنا
وشركائنا الدوليين
رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه قال ان القوات
المسلحه اتمت عمليه اجراء معقده وسريعه
للدبلوماسيين البريطانيين وعائلاتهم من
السودان مضيفا ان بريطانيا تسعى بكل
الوسائل لوقف اراقه الدماء في السودان
وضمان سلامه البريطانيين المت بقين هناك
وانها تحث الاطراف كافه على القاء الاسلحه
وايقاف اطلاق النار
قال وزير الدفاع البريطاني على صفحته على
تويتر ان القوات المسلحه البريطانيه نفذت
عمليه الى جانب الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
وحلفاء اخرين واجلت موظفي السفاره
البريطانيه وعائلاتهم من الخرطوم بسبب
التهديدات المتصاعده مشيرا الى مشاركه
1200 جندي بريطاني في العمليه منهم سته
عشر لواء هجوم جوي ومشاه البحريه الملكيه
وسلاح الجو المالكي البريطاني
الليله الماضيه اجرى الجيش البريطاني
عمليه اجلاء للموظفين الدبلوماسيين
البريطانيين وعائلاتهم من الخرطوم
باستخدام عناصر من اللواء السادس عشر هجوم
جوي وسلاح الجو الملكي ومشات البحريه
الملكيه ساهم اكثر من 1200 شخص في هذه
العمليه المحفوفه بالمخاطر لكننا مع ذلك
تمكنا من استخدام طائرات سي 130 وايه 400
للدخول وجمع دبلوماسيين والمقيمين معهم
والطيران الى بر الامان
اعلن الاتحاد الاوروبي عن اجلاء بعثته في
السودان بامان وكان ممثل سياسه الخارجيه
بالاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوري قال انه حتى
قائدي الجيش السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
وقوات الدعم السريعه محمد حمدان دقلو على
الوقف الفوري لاطلاق النار واضافه انه اكد
للبرهان ودجلو ضروره حمايه المدنيين
اجلب حكومات اجنبيه واجل الدبلوماسيين
وموظفين اخرين محاصرين في السودان في
الوقت الذي يشتبك فيه القاده العسكريون
المتنافسون لليوم التاسع بدون اي مؤشر على
تهدئه حقيقيه قريبه
لم يصمت الرصاص في السودان في هدى تم
الاتفاق عليها ما دفع الدولة للبدء
بعمليات اجلاء رعاياها تحت النار تصدرت
السعوديه الدول التي اجلت رعاياها ورعايه
دول اخرى باول عمليه اجلاء لمدنيين حيث
نقلت القوات البحريه السعوديه اكثر من 150
شخصا من السعوديين ورعاي دول اخرى من
بورسودان الى جده عبر البحر الاحمر
ووسط تبادل الجيش وقوات حملت الاتهامات
بشان اطلاق النار اثناء عمليه اجلاء رعايه
فرنسيين كان احدها هؤلاء الرعايه قد اصيب
ولفتت الخارجيه الفرنسيه الى ان اجلاء
رعاياها يشمل ايضا مواطنين اوروبيين ودول
حليفه بدورها بدات بريطانيا والمانيا
واسبانيا في اجلاء رعاياها كما ارسلت
اليونان طائرات وقوات خاصه الى مصر
استعدادا لاجلاء 120 يونانيا وقبرصيا من
الخرط كذلك فعلت هولندا بارسال طائرتين
تابعتين للسلاح الجو وطائره مدنيه الى
الاردن استباقا لمهمه انقاذ محتمله فيما
اوفدت ايطاليا طائرات عسكريه الى دوله
جيبوتي استعدادا لاجلاء 140 من رعاياها في
السودان كما حدث كل من الاردن ولبنان حدوه
تلك الدول وارسل الطائرات تقل رعاياها
بالاضافه الى رعايه عرب واجانب كما اعلن
الاردن على لسان جيشه فيما بدا الرئيس
الامريكي مرتاحا لاجلاء 70 شخصا هم موظفوا
سفره الامريكيه في الخرطوم الى اثيوبيا
وبخلاف الرعب الذي يحرم حول عمليات
الاجلاء المهدده باشتعال القتال في اي وقت
فهناك تعقيدات اخرى منها شلل المطار
الرئيسي اضافه الى ايقاف تشغيل المطارات
الاخرى في انحاء السودان حنان المصري
العربيه
مساء الخير طاهر ياتي العمليه المعقده جدا
لا تزال الجهات المسؤوله تتكتم على
تفاصيل خاصه الفنيه والعملانيه في بالنسبه
لعمليات ولكن ما توفر من معلومات يفيد من
ان قوات خاصه تابعه للقوات الفرنسيه
والالمانيه وربما ايضا الهولنديه رابطت
يعني المئات رابطوا في مطار وادي سيدنا
شمال شمال العاصمه الخرطوم على بعد عشرين
كيلومتر وهذا المطار توجد به مهبط امن
بنسبه للطائرات التي تاتي من القاعده
الفرنسيه من جيبوتي او ربما من اماكن اخرى
هناك تم تجميع الرعايه الفرنسيين
والاوروبيين بصفه عامه الذين نقلوا اما
بوسائلهم الخاصه مثلما هو الحال او لمكان
الحال بالنسبه للرعايه الالمان او الذين
في قوافل العسكريه محميه من الناحيه
العسكريه
شقت الخرطوم مثل الرعايه الفرنسيين
والاوروبيين وهناء في هذه يعني في هذا
الجانب المعقد جدا في نقل الرعايه من داخل
العاصمه او من ضواحيها الى هذا المطار
مطار وادي سيدنا في شمال الخرطوم اصيب
هناك في هذه العمليه احد الرعايه
الفرنسيين لان العمليه معقده جدا والرعايه
ومن يحميهم كانوا يعني يتوجب عليهم ان
يشقوا خاصه خطوط المواجهه وهي ليس بخط
واحد وانما خطوط كثيره بين مجموعات مسلحه
تابعه لقوات الدعم السريع او للقوات
المسلحه السودانيه من هناك نقل الرعايه
على متن طائره عسكريه
فرنسيه اوروبيه تصنع اي 400 ام من شمال
الخرطوم نحو القاعده الفرنسيه في جيبوتي
من هناك طبعا يتم اجلؤهم الى بلدانهم قبل
ذلك كان مثل ما تفضلت
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه جوزيف بوليل تحدث
الى الجنرلين حميدتي والبرهان ولكن ايضا
كان في غضور نهار تحدث الى الامير
فيصل بن فرحان وزير الخارجي السعودي حيث
اكد جوزيف انه يشترك مع الجانب السعودي في
القلق الشديد من هذه الحرب ووجوب مواصله
العمل الجماعي من اجل تامين وقف اطلاق
النار في اقرب عظيم ولكن هل نتوقع مبادره
ما من جانب الاتحاد الاوروبي تحتل هل
نتوقع مبادره ما
هز عصا عقوبات على جانب من الجانبين او
على الجانبين هل يريد الانخراط في هذا
الصراع الى هذا الحد ام انه يريد ان يخرج
منه بالحد الادنى من الخسائر بين الطرفين
سفير الاتحاد الاوروبي لم يغادر الخرطومه
بقي ربما مع ادنى المساعدين في العاصمه
الخرطوم من اجل مواصله التواسل مع طرفي
النزاع والمساعده خاصه مساعده المبادرات
الاخرى التي تقوم بها ايجاد او الامم
المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي وكذلك بعض
المساعدات التي ياتي او الجهود التي
تبذلها بعض الدول العربيه مثل مصر
والامارات العربيه المتحده والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه وبالتالي في هذه المرحله
يمكن القول طاهر ان الاتحاد الاوروبي يفضل
المسانده من الخلف للمبادرات الاقليميه او
المبادرات خاصه التي يقوم بها الاتحاد
الافريقي والمتحده في هذه المرحله بالذات
لهذا السبب بقي السفير الاوروبي
يداموا رغم التوتر الذي يسيطر على المنطقه
ويوم يعني يوم صباح الاثنين وزراء خارجيه
الاتحاد الاوروبي سيبحثون عمليه الاجلاء
بصفه عامه وربما تنسيق الجهود وخاصه دعم
ما يتوفر من جهود اقليميه ودوليه لمحاوله
احتواء هذا النزاع ونحن سنتابع معك طبعا
تغطيه هذا الاجتماع وما سيخرج به من
قرارات وتوصيات اجتماع وزراء الخارجيه
الاوروبيين في لوكسمبورج ولكن اريد ان
اسالك عموما بعيدا عن البعثات الاوروبيه
والمصالح الاوروبيه المباشره ما العناوين
العريضه التي يعنى بها الاتحاد الاوروبي
كاتحاد او كدول اوروبيه
في السودان او في هذا الصراع تحديدا بين
الرجلين عندما نريد ان نتخيل لماذا يجب او
كيف او حجم التدخل الذي يجب ان يكون عليه
الحال بالنسبه الى الاتحاد الاوروبي عندما
يتعلق الموضوع بالسودان ماذا نقول
خوف الاوروبيين من توسع النزاع خارج
الخرطوم وان يطال مدنا سودانيه سودانيه
اخرى وان يتحول هذا النزاع بين القوتين
العسكريتين الى حرب اهليه ثانيا الخوف كل
الخوف من ان تفلت الاوضاع
وخاصه الامن في حدود السودان مع الدول
العديده وهي سبع دول تقريبا وانا ذاك قد
يفلت الامر وتتحول الازمه الى كوارث
انسانيه وكوارث من اللاجئين تشقق من تحت
الساحل الافريقي هناك من يقارن الوضع في
في السودان اليوم بانه قد يشبه بعد وقت
قصير ما شهدته ليبيا من انقسام ومن تدخلات
خارجيه السودان ايضا بدوره يخضع لهذه
التدخلات او يتاثروا بهذه التدخلات منذ
سنوات طهر شكرا جزيلا عموما الدول يعني
شمال افريقيا يمكن ان تشكل هذا الخطر اذا
تسرب
التسربت اعداد اللاجئين السودانيين كما
تسربت اعداد اللاجئين السابقين من هذه
الدول الى شمال المتوسط الاوروبي شكرا
جزيلا لك نور الدين الفريدي مراسل العربيه
من لوكسمبورج على كل هذه التوضيحات
والمعلومات ولا نعود اليك لتغطيه هذا
المؤتمر الذي تحدثنا عنه للتو تحياتي اليك
قالت وزاره الخارجيه الاثيوبيه انما يحدث
في السودان شان داخلي وان اثيوبيا مستعده
للوساطه اذا طلب منها ذلك اضافت الخارجيه
الاثيوبيه ان اديس ابا تسعى لتهدئه
الاوضاع في السودان بعيدا عن التقارير
الوهميه مشيره الى انه لسقط للتقارير التي
تتحدث عن تدخل لاثيوبيا في السودان
وشدادات الخارجيه الاثيوبيه على انها
تراقب عن كثب وضع الجاليه الاثيوبيه
الموجوده في السودان
موقع السودان المتميز في القاره الافريقيه
جعله عالقا بشبكه مصالح اقليميه ودوليه
واسعه تلقي بظلالها بشكل مستمر على مشهده
السياسي الداخلي
لا هدنى صمدت ولا حسم يلوح بالافق نوبات
قتال شرعت لها ارض السودان الخصبه
للنزاعات مع غياب استعداد للتسويه شبكه من
المصالح والتقاطعات الاقليميه والدوليه
القت بظلالها على مشهد السودان السياسي
باستمرار في ظل موقعه الافريقي المتميز
ومساعي طي الازمه السياسيه افرز التقسيمات
في تعامل بعض الدول مع الازمه
علاقات الخرطوم المتميزه بالروس ليست
جديده تعد موسكو حليفا دبلوماسيا وعسكريا
لها تمكنت من خلالها توسيع حلقات تعاونها
الامني مع السودان خاصه مع امتلاك الاخير
موقعا مهما على البحر الاحمر المصالح وصلت
الى كنز السودان المدفون الذهب
اتهم الغرب مجموعه فاجن الروسيه بالتورط
في انشطه غير قانونيه لتعدين الذهب في
السودان اما بالنسبه للجناح الغربي
وواشنطن فسعاد التخلص من البشير التي
تتهمه المحكمه الدوليه بارتكاب جرائم حرب
اثناء الصراع في دارفور لم تملا تصدعات
هذا البلد الهش كما اتهمت واشنطن بالتلكؤ
في دعم الانتقال نحو اجراء انتخابات اما
بالنسبه للصين يعد السودان حلقه وصل مهمه
بين المحيطين العربي والافريقي لكنها تبنت
نهجا اكثر حذرا تجاه الصراع في السودان
اتسعى الى الحفاظ على التوازن بين مصالح
الاقتصاديه والالتزام بعدم التدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه للدول الاخرى
الصراع بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع اجذب مشاركه كبيره من اللاعبين
الاقليميين والدوليين ولكل منهم دوافعه
ومصالحه الخاصه اياد حمود العربيه
الباحثه
بالمعنى الجغرافي اولا موقع السودان
يعطيها اهميه كبيره لجهه من يمكن ان يتدخل
في شؤونه الداخليه بحكم الاوضاع السياسيه
والى اي مدى هل هذا العامل باعتقادك هو
الاساسي الان فيما يمكن ان تؤول اليه
الامور من تدخلات ام
المشاريع الاقليميه والدوليه وما يخص
السودان منها
اهلا بك طاهر وبمشاهدي قناه العربيه لا شك
ان السودان يعني صاحب موقع استراتيجي مهم
على حوض النيل على البحر الاحمر على
القاره الافريقيه بشكل اساسي يعني لديه
الان بعد اقتطاع جنوب السودان لديه حدود
مع سبع دول ايضا لديها مشاكل سياسيه وتخشى
من انزلاق الامور
واقترابها الى الى بلدانها التي تعانيها
المشاكل الاقتصاديه وسياسيه والى ما هنالك
وبالتالي هناك استثمار حقيقي يمكن ان يحصل
في الاسباب الداخليه التي ادت الى هذا
النزاع العسكري بمعنى
ليس علينا دائما ان نبحث عن الايادي
الخارجيه التي قادت الى مثل هذا الصراع
هناك من الظروف الداخليه التي ادت الى
حصول صراع عسكري مسلح ما بين البرهان
وحميتي ما يكفي
الان هل يمكن الاستثمار بذلك طبعا ويبدو
ان هناك اطراف تستثمر في هذا النزاع سواء
على المستوى الاقليمي وسواء على المستوى
الدولي لو بدات دوليا على سبيل المثال
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي تركت
السودان طويلا لشانه بمعنى ان في فتره 30
سنه لحكم البشير لم تكن الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه منخرطه فعليا اخذت فرضت عقوبات
تم يعني ايضا محاكمه البشير في المحكمه
الجنائيه بمعنى صدر حكم عليه وتم ايضا
تصنيف السودان بوصفها دوله رعيه الارهاب
ولكن اكثر من ذلك لم يكن هناك من يعني
تدخلات امريكيه واضحه في حين استطاعت
الصين وروسيا العدواني او الخصمان
الاساسيان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
الساحه الدوليه ان تفرض وجودهما في
السودان كما جاء في التقرير كما في يعني
الكلام السابق قبل قليل العربيه نعم هناك
استثمار في التعدين وبخاصه الذهب في جبل
عامر من قبل جماعه فاجنر التي على ما يبدو
حسب الكثير من التقارير انها ارسلت الكثير
من الذهب والمعادن لتدعم الاحتياطي الروسي
في مواجهه العقوبات
الغربيه عليها من ناحيه اخرى الصين ايضا
او قبل ان نذهب الى الصين ايضا يعني حميتي
يبدو انه يعني واضح انه قد منح قاعده
عسكريه لروسيا على البحر الاحمر الصين
ايضا تستثمر في المعادن ولديها مصالح
اقتصاديه قويه جعلت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تقتنص فرصه
يعني انهاء حكم البشير لتدخل بقوه داعمه
المجتمع المدني قيام مثل هذا التغير نحو
الديمقراطيه في السودان منه يعني دفع عن
الديمقراطيه ولكن قبل ذلك مص التي تقتضي
الا تترك يعني السودان بمساحته القاريه
الكبيره
نهبا لخصميها اللدودين طيب بس خلينا
اجزاء مما تفضلت به يعني عندما تحدثنا عن
الجغرافيا واهميتها في هذا البلد الغني
اللي يعد سله من سلال غذاء العالم مجتمعا
ان زرع
هل نتحدث عن اهميته بهذا المعنى الجغرافيا
يعني بحر احمر ونيل وثروه والى ما هنالك
وهذا ما يجعل الصراع قائما وربما يتمدد او
وبالتالي المصالح الاقتصاديه للدول الكبرى
او المشاريع السياسيه العقاديه التي نسمع
عنها في الاتهامات المتبادله بين اخوانهم
اخوان نظام سابق ومش نظام سابق والى ما
هنالك
الان المصالح الاقتصاديه والجيو
استراتيجيه للدول الكبرى لا شك انها حاضره
ولكنها ليست بتلك القوه بعد اقتطاع يعني
جنوب السودان ذهب ثلاث ارباع المصادر
النفطيه
لجنوب السودان لم يبقى هناك الكثير مما
يسيل لعاب الغرب نفطيا ومع ذلك يظل
السودان بلد غني بثرواته الزراعيه يعني
امكانيه زراعته كما تفضلت مهمه جدا هناك
استثمارات اقليميه وعربيه يجب دعمها وهي
حقيقيه وقويه ربما المملكه العربيه
السعوديه من اكبر المستثمرين زراعيا في
السودان وبالتالي هناك لا شك نوع من
المصالح والصراعات والى ما هنالك لكن كل
ذلك لا يفسر سبب
الذراع الحرب واستمرارها هناك الان ما بقي
يعني الخوف من
القضايا بتصوري الان هو الخوف من الاسوا
وليس البحث عن الافضل بمعنى ما يمكن ان
على سبيل المثال وكما جاء يعني في كلمتك
بعد بعد المراسل نور الدين كانت مهمه ما
يقلق اوروبا تحديدا ليس مصالحها في
السودان مصالحها تراجعت بعد ذلك المصالح
الاستعمار الاستعماريه الكبيره حيث كانت
بريطانيا منتدبه على السودان لفتره طويله
لا لم يعد ذلك موجودا الان اوروبا اصبحت
ضعيفه وبدات تخرج من من القاره الافريقيه
مهزومه امام ليس فقط الصين وروسيا وانما
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لكن تخشى
اوروبا بشكل كبير الان ان يؤدي هذا الصراع
الذي ياتي في زمن تاتالت فيه هي ازمه
كورونا لسنوات ثم الحرب في اوكرانيا
والحروب في العالم في الشرق الاوسط وموجات
الهجره التي بدات تؤثر بشكل كبير عليه فقط
على السياسه الغربيه وانما على ايضا
الاقتصاد الغربي الذي يعاني من حاله تضخم
كبيره وهي ليست بحاجه الى فتح باب جديد
يعني
تثور فيها الرياح المهاجرين والمشاكل
اسالك لماذا باعتقادك في حاله بغض النظر
عن موقف اي طرف من من دوله او اقليمي من
اي طرف داخلي ولكن هناك رئيس مجلس السياده
يعني اعترف فيه في النتيجه وهناك وهو رايي
القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
ويقود البلد لماذا عندما اصطدم مع فصيل
بالنتيجه مهما كانت قوته وهي قوات الدعم
السريع بغض النظر عن الموقف منها وعن مدى
احقيتها او عدم احقيتها فيما تفعله لماذا
الدول العالم لم يكن لها موقف حاسم بكل
بساطه مع الدوله مع النظام مع الجيش مع
المؤسسه العسكريه القوات المسلحه يعني في
مواقف كثيره اما متذبذبه او متناقضه او
بين بين او مائعه او غير واضحه على الاقل
ما السبب الذي تعطيه لذلك
يعني هناك جمله اسباب اهمها ربما بشكل
اساسي عدم وجود مصالح حقيقيه كبرى الان
اقتصاديه
واستعماراتيه ومع ذلك هي موجوده ولكن ليست
بذلك الشكل الذي يدفع الدول كما فعل مثلا
حينما
اندلعت الثوره في ليبيا ان يتحرك بسرعه
هائله لانقاذ ما كان يدعي يعني
بشكل اساسي حلف الناتو وحتى الامم المتحده
بانه لانقاذ مدينه بنغازي صحيحه هناك نفط
هناك مصالح كبرى في ليبيا تستدعي ذلك الان
السودان الفقير المفقر يعني هو ليس فقير
حقيقه ولكن المفقر بعد 30 سنه من الفساد
وحكومه الاسلام السياسي في فتره عمر
البشير ثم ذلك الصراع يعني من 2019
والحلم حقيقه بتكوين دوله ديمقراطيه مدنيه
اقصد على الاقل لم يحدث نتيجه الصراع
العسكر نتيجه المصالح والمطامع ما بين
الشقين واظن ان
على
العمليه المدنيه وعلى الاتفاق الايطالي
لانه لا يريده مع الاتهامات التي نعرفها
من طرف البرهان لسيد حماتي تفضل
يا عزيزي نعم يعني شكرا للعربيه التي
استطاعت ان تجمع هذين الخصمين نتمنى ان
يعني ان تستطيع ان تجمع ربما يوما قاده
للسودان متسامح وبدون حروب ولكن كل واحد
كان يسوق نفسه سواء على العربيه سواء ولكن
بشكل خاص ما تم تصريحه يعني جميل الحواريه
الذي اقمتموها كل واحد كيف يصرح حول هذه
النقطه من طرف كل واحد يصور نفسه انه يعني
تحرك عسكريا من اجل السودان من اجل الدوله
المدنيه كل واحد يسوق نفسه الان بانه صديق
للدول الجوار صديق للغرب صديق للدوله
المدنيه ضد
انقلاب الاخر على الشرعيه وبالتالي ولكن
ما يحصل حقيقه حميدتي ايضا لديه مصالح
كبيره كانت ستنتهي لو تم التوافق الايطالي
بمعنى انه يتم ادماج قوات الدعم السريع
ضمن الجيش وبالتالي هو سيخضع بشكل كامل
الى سلطه البرهان وتلك الميليشيات يعني
التي يعني هي هي بالنهايه يعني اعاده
تدوير للجنجاويد جماعه الجنجويد والى ما
هنالك كانت التي بدات منذ ايام النظام
السابق ولكن عموما هو يقول انه ايضا السيد
برهان وفريق الجيش يقول بانه
لا يريد اتمام عمليه الدمج التي تم
الاتفاق عليها وبالتالي قام بمقام به اذا
كما قلنا اتهامات متبادله دكتور اريد ان
اعود معك الى الشق الدولي هل يعني المواقف
ليست واضحه مئه بالمئه ولكن بناء على
المصالح الدوليه التي تحدثنا عنها مثلا
اذا تحدثنا عن روسيا الصين الولايات
المتحده فرنسا وبريطانيا كاعضاء دائمين في
مجلس الامن هل تتخيل انه بناء على مصالحهم
ستكون عقبه كبيره امام اتخاذ اي قرار ملزم
من مجلس الامن ام انهم سيصطدمون مجددا
يعني لحد الان التصريحات رغم اختلاف
المصالح تدعو الى التهدئه حتى الصين صرحت
بشكل واضح التهدئه الصوت الاكثر غيابا اذا
او اللي نسمعه بسبب غيابه الكبير هو روسيا
يعني روسيا الان والتي يعني
قويه هناك وهناك حديث حتى عن تدريب فاجنر
ما هي تقارير لا يمكن التاكد منها لحد
يعني الان بشكل سريع ولكن هناك مصالح
روسيه كبيره ربما تعطل اتخاذ قرار في
الامم المتحده امام مجلس الامن ولكن اسمح
لي ان يعني هناك الان توجه نحو فرض عقوبات
دوليه على هذين الرجلين
واللذان يعني والجيش الذي يتبع لهما
والمؤسسات ولكن يعني قناعتي الشخصيه ان
فرض العقوبات سيزيد الطينه بالله لماذا
لان اولا كل شخص الان يحارب بطريقه
انتحاريه هو يعرف تماما انه اما غالب او
مغلوب ولا يوجد حل امامه في حال انتصر
الطرف الاخر يعني هناك
انهاء وجودي لي
للخاسر او محاكم عسكريه وابتلي هناك كارثه
تنتظره وبالتالي هنا يقاتلون بشراسه لان
ظهرهم الى الجدار ليس ورائهم ما يخسرونه
وبالتالي فرض العقوبات سيزيدوا من شراسه
هذه هذين الشخصين والجنرالا او اذا كان
هناك
تزكيه من الخارج او تحريض من الخارج او
سمه ما شئت لشخصيه ما قادره على كسب الجيش
وربما الاطاحه بالطرفين معا والقيام
بانقلاب جديد كما حصل كثيرا سابقا في
السودان
صحيح صحيح وبالتالي يعني ايضا في موضوع
العقوبات بشكل اساسي يعني شاهدنا ذلك في
في العقوبات التي فرضت على ايران في
العقوبات التي فرضت على سوريا في العقوبات
التي فرضت على البشير الشعب ليس بمنع
بالعكس هو هو اول متضررين
ومن تفرض عليه العقوبات حتى بالاسماء يظل
يعني لديهم محمي ولديه الفروه والماء
ليبقى ويستمر والى ما هنالك لكن اسمح لي
يعني اتصور ان الحل الافضل الذي يمكن فعلا
المضيه بهم يعني يعتمد على نقطتين تجفيف
تسليح هذه الجماعات بالنهايه الذخيره
لديها ستنفذ
يعني الا اذا استمر الدعم لها وتسريب
الاسلحه لها من عبر الحدود الكثيره وغير
المضبوطه يجب وضع قوات على الاقل حدوديه
دوليه تمارس الرقابه بشكل واضح على تهريب
الاسلحه الى احد الطرفين
الجانب الاخر ايجاد يعني ح يضمن ليس فقط
العداله ستؤجل الان البحث عن العداله
ومعاقبه طرفين وانما مخرج امن لكليهما
والا لان كل شخص الان فعلا في ازمه وجوديه
ويحارب يعني يعني اما قاتل او مقتوله
وبالتالي لابد من ايجاد مخارج هكذا بتصور
يمكن ضبط الحدود من اجل عدم تهريب الاسلحه
الايجاد مخرج امن لكلا الجنرلين
المتصارعين وابعادهما عن حياه السياسيه
كما حصل مع البشير يعني في فتره من في
2019 تم ابعاد البشير وانقلب عليه يعني
دجله كان كان احد يعني هو جنرالاته في في
في
دارفور والى ما هنالك الان يمكن كما تم
ازاحه البشير يمكن ازاحه هذين الطرفين وهو
عندها يجب العمل وبخاصه العربي
وربما كان هناك الرباعيه يجب تفعيل دورها
السعوديه الامارات بريطانيا وامريكا
الوضع امور وربما دوليه تحت الباندا
السابع بحمايه الدوله المدنيه التي يجب ان
تكون وفقا لاتفاق الايطالي ربما معتديلات
من مناقشه اوسع ولكن العسكري يجب عليه ان
يتوقف وبالتالي بتصور يعني جانبا اساسيا
ايقاف تهريب الاسلحه وايجاد مخرج يعني
لكلا الجنرلين والا فالحرب مستمره الى الى
وهي للاسف في هذه الاحوال تكون تجاره
رائجه لدى عدد من الاطراف في الكثير من
الدول عموما يعني لا يعني لا شك بانه
مرحله ما بعد الخامس عشر من ابريل ستفرد
الكثير من التغيرات على المشهدين السياسي
والعسكريه في السودان وهو ما نرقبه اولا
باول في هذه التغطيه المتواصله من العربيه
شكرا لوجودك معنا فيها البحث السياسي
دكتور خلدون النبواني من باريس تحياتي
اليك
[موسيقى]
اصبحت مدينه الاوبيض الان امنه سالمه
هانئه مطمئنه ندعو جميع المواطنين لفتح
الاسواق ومزاوله اعمالهم من صباح الغد
[تصفيق]
اصبحت المدينه امنه مطمئنه
على صعيد جهود الدوليه والاقليميه بحث
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان مع مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي بحث جهودا المبذوله لوقف
التصعيد العسكري بين الاطراف المتنازعه
وانهاء العنف السودان اضافه الى توفير
الحمايه اللازمه للمدنيين السودانيين
والمقيمين مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي كشف عن توافق سعودي
اوروبي على العمل الجماعي من اجل وقف
اطلاق النار في السودان
ايضا وزير الخارجيه السعودي بحث هاتفيا مع
رئيس وزراء قطر وزير الخارجيه محمد بن عبد
الرحمن بن جاسم الفاني جهود وقف التصعيد
العسكري في السودان وناقش الوزيران ايضا
جهود توفير الحمايه اللازمه للمدنيين
السودانيين وتهدئه التوترات المتصاعده في
العديد من المواقع الحيويه داخل السودان
في الكويت عاد اليوم 25 مواطنا قادمين من
مطار جده الدولي في السعوديه وذلك في اطار
الخطه الطارئه التي نفذتها وزاره الخارجيه
الكويتيه لاجلاء المواطنين العالقين جراء
الاشتباكات المسلحه والتطورات الامنيه في
السودان
[موسيقى]
طالبت منظمه الصحه العالميه بعدم استهداف
المرافق الصحيه والعاملين والمرضى في
السودان بعدما وثقت المنظمه عده هجمات
مميته استهدفت مؤسسات الصحيه ويعاني
القطاع الطبي في السودان من اوضاع صعبه
زادها النزاع الدائر حاليا سوءا
كما العاده في كل النزاعات والصراعات
المدنيون هم الضحيه الاكبر لها وهذا وضع
السوداني اليوم جثث ملقاه في الشوارع وما
من جهه تتمكن من نقلها لمثواها الاخير مع
تضارب الاحصاءات حول عدد القتلى بين
الجهات المحليه والدوليه فترات هدنه
المتقطعه لم توفر ممرات امنه لتخفيف وطئه
النزاع وتاثيرها على المواطن السوداني
مكتب الشؤون الانسانيه بالامم المتحده رصد
مقتل 413 شخصا واصابه ثلاثه الاف وخمسمائه
اخرين في الاشتباكات حتى الحادي والعشرين
من ابريل الجاري بحسب التقرير سجلت
الخرطوم اعلى عدد من القتلى ب122 ثلاث
ولايه شمال كردفان بخمسه وتسعين قتيلا ثم
ولايه شمال دارفور بواحد وستين قتيلا في
عدد المرشح للزياده المعوقات اللي نحن
بنواجهك هلال احمد سوداني تواجه كل
المنظمات الانسانيه العامله في السودان
اللي هي ابرز عدم توفر المسارات الامنه
وما في ضمانات لوقف اطلاق النار بين
الاطراف المتنازعه من جانبها اعلنت نقابه
الاطباء ان 72% من المستشفيات القريبه من
مناطق الاشتباك توقفت عن الخدمه من اصل 79
مستشفى اساسيا في العاصمه والولايات من
المجموع الكلي للمستشفيات بقي اثنتان
وعشرون مستشفى تعمل بشكل كامل او جزئي
لكنها تبقى مهدده بالاغلاق نتيجه نقص
الكوادر والامدادات الطبيه وانقطاع الماء
والكهرباء كما ان عده مناطق يكثر فيها
الجرحى لا تستطيع الطواقم الطبيه الوصول
اليها بيان نقابه الاطباء اضاف ان اربعه
مستشفيات في مدينه الاوبيض تعرضت للقصف ما
يرفع العدد الكلي للمستشفيات التي قصفت
الى 13 مستشفى
اليها تسعه عشر مستشفى تعرضت للاخلاء
القصري كما تعرضت ست مركبات اسعاف
للاعتداء من قبل قوات عسكريه بينما لم يتم
السماح لعدد من سيارات الاسعاف بالمرور
لنقل المرضى وايصال المعونات حسب ما قالت
نقابه اطباء السودان من جانبه طالب الهلال
الاحمر بتحييد المنشات الطبيه عن العمليات
القتاليه لتجنب الانهيار الكامل للقطاع
الصحي في السودان حسن جوليد العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات